- [David] Hello, readers.
Today I wanna talk about examples
and how writers use them
in informational text.
As writers, we employ examples
to help explain ideas.
And as readers, we use those examples
to grab hold of those ideas
and better understand them.
If I tell you that I have weird hobbies,
I need to back up that
statement with some examples.
I need to illustrate
just how weird they are.
So if I say my hobbies
include going for walks,
reading books, and drinking tea,
those are very ordinary interests,
they're not weird at all.
Not a good example.
I need to be more selective
and better support my claim
that my hobbies are strange.
So instead, I could say my
hobbies include puppeteering,
making bubble tea from scratch,
and learning to read Middle English.
Well, now we're getting somewhere, right?
Now you're starting to understand
just how much of a
weirdo this David guy is.
What is the function of an example?
What does it do?
When you come across an example,
ask yourself, what purpose
does this example serve?
Why did the author
introduce this detail here?
How does this example
connect to the text overall?
Does it form a pattern with other details?
And if so, what does that pattern tell me?
And finally we ask ourselves,
does this example raise other questions?
Let's look at a text and
evaluate its examples.
Here's an excerpt from a piece
about the author J.M. Barrie,
the creator of "Peter Pan".
"Barrie didn't have just one version
"of the "Peter Pan" story,
"he made changes along the way.
"For example, he learned
"that children were copying Peter Pan
"and trying to jump out
of their beds to fly.
"Some of them were getting badly injured!
"So Barrie added the rule
that in order to fly,
"you had to have fairy or pixie dust
"blown on you first.
"By adding this rule,
"J.M. Barrie was trying to
help children understand
"that flying is magical,
"so that they wouldn't try
to do it themselves and get hurt."
So the author is saying that
J.M. Barrie changed "Peter Pan"
and then he gives an
example of the change.
Let's zero in on that example
and ask those questions
that we just went over.
So for this example,
what is its purpose?
Well, it does a couple of things.
It shows us that J.M. Barrie was willing
to make changes to his story
after it was initially published.
It shows us that the author
wants to portray Barrie
as a responsible person.
He heard about children
injuring themselves
by copying his story
and so he made an effort to prevent that
by changing a detail in the story.
It's also a pretty specific
example that I can picture.
I can imagine kids
jumping off of tall things
and getting hurt,
and Barrie feeling worried about that.
And because I can picture it,
I can better understand it,
which helps me better
understand the overall text.
I only excerpted a small
portion of this text.
So I'm not gonna ask how it
connects to the text overall.
But this example does raise
other questions for me,
like what other children's fiction
accidentally encourages people
to do dangerous stunts at home?
Like jumping off your bed?
Examples are really powerful!
They can shape a reader's
impression of a topic.
As a writer, employ them tactically
to help develop someone's understanding.
Recognize that when a series
of examples comes in sequence,
it tells a story,
and story is an incredibly powerful tool.
Use it responsibly.
As a reader, understand the
power that examples have
and pay attention to
how they're being used.
A well-chosen example or two
can create a false narrative.
As readers, we are engaged in
a push and pull with writers,
especially when they are trying
to convince us of something.
Make a writer work to convince you.
Read with a skeptical attitude.
And if you can do that,
you can learn anything.
David, out.